okay give me a second it is
nerve-racking holy smokes this is my
producer Kendall
we had a family-size team so I wanted to
do my best to thank them all for taking
a chance on this film and investing time
and talent that went above and beyond my
wildest dream well we made a wild film
I want to thank Kendall her producer
whose undying commitment to these
projects occurred way before patron
saint's on this film she not only
produced but first a deed and acted damn
that's like a mm-hmm thank you for your
years of hard work and belief in my
vision I know words will never do
justice to the level of appreciation I
have for you thank you also to change in
and Greg also if you worked on the film
come come up I'm nerve-racked so if you
worked on with um yeah yeah thank you
thanks thank you also to change in and
Greg I couldn't imagine shooting a piece
without y'all and Isaac and Josue you've
also been with me since day one I've
never shot a film without their support
they're my family thank you to the stars
Monroe yeah Leah DeSean and Jesse to the
art team Po and Sonny for manifesting my
vision with such few resources to the
hair and makeup team headed by jaws and
Bianca to all of our other contributors
thank you to my family
it is a privilege in this world to have
a family who supports and loves you
unconditionally and not when I take for
granted thank you to my friends Alex
Sean Jan Chaka Elam and Zach for your
support especially throughout
post-production thank you so much to the
Academy for selecting our film for this
honor it means an incredible amount to
demonstrate how meaningful beautiful and
impactful and alternative media can be
especially when reframing exploring the
lights of people usually designated as
alternative when as for whom he created
art Felix gonzalez-torres all simply
said his partners named Ross his work
was a love letter and I share that
sentiment that art is an exchange
between individuals that is personal and
can speak to the universal this piece is
a love letter to my career community and
the possibility of a fashion in so many
ways to Kenan Jamal especially when
words failed me I want to extend a huge
thank you to Jamal for trusting me with
his art
when you see yourself in your community
on screen within a grim reality it is
deeply meaningful to have the
opportunity to create a fantastical
environment which people like you can
live
I hope media continues takes for the
possibilities of portraying the magic of
our community in a ways that tests and
push the ways we are conceptualized for
the screen I'm so grateful for the
economy for allowing us to be part of
this history and do you want to say
something thank you to Jordan thank you
to the Academy and to my mama and to
Winslow and to chase thank you so much
guys
[Applause]